bueno justamente Santiago Lo que
critican los sindicatos que ha
manifestado de manera relativamente
pacífica estas últimas semanas es que en
el parlamento la situación no es similar
no es pacífica tanto el gobierno como la
izquierda se acusan de obstruir El
Debate parlamentario la izquierda porque
ha presentado muchas enmiendas a este
proyecto y el gobierno porque cae
justamente las polémicas de la izquierda
la última la del diputado toma aportes
de la frase en sumisa de que se sacó una
foto con No es cierto la banda
presidencial tricolor y con una pelota
de fútbol en los pies con la cabeza del
ministro del trabajo eso ocupó la
polémica Ayer no hubo debate la asamblea
nacional fue expulsado por quince
sesiones y también se le quitó dos meses
el sueldo de parlamentario por falta de
respeto y así no avanza el debate en
medio de esta polémica ya se aprobó un
primer artículo aquel que suprime estos
regímenes especiales de jubilaciones que
era justamente una de las grandes
medidas que quería el gobierno de
Emmanuel macron eliminar esos regímenes
para que todo el mundo tenga el mismo
sistema de jubilaciones se aprobó
obviamente gracias al oficialismo y el
apoyo de la derecha